Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Ça y est, nous y sommes,
en plein changement.
Il ne faut pas croire que
le changement va être devant,
on y est, les êtres vivants le ressentent
depuis très longtemps
et le ressentent de façon intense.
Face aux changements
et aux perturbations climatiques,
souvent, vous allez entendre
des solutions qui vont émerger.
Rapides, lapidaires :
arrêter l’élevage, planter des milliers
d’arbres et ça va suffire.
Or, le problème face auquel
on est est un problème complexe.
Pour les êtres vivants, le changement
n’est pas le fond du problème.
Le fond du problème, c’est la vitesse avec
laquelle ce changement va se produire.
Le changement est
le moteur de l’évolution ;
les êtres vivants se sont adaptés
depuis des millions d’années.
Par contre, ils s’adaptent sur du
long terme, sur du multigénérationnel.
Or maintenant, le changement -
vous l’avez vu dans les films projetés -
ce sont des éléments extrêmement rapides.
Alors pourquoi la prairie ?
Simplement parce que c’est un écosystème
qui est composé d’espèces herbacées
et qui ont tendance à pousser assez vite,
beaucoup plus vite en tout cas
que les arbres,
des espèces ligneuses qui vont
se développer sur des longues générations.
Pour nous, en tant que chercheurs,
c’est un modèle extrêmement intéressant
parce qu’on va pouvoir observer
en temps réel des changements.
C’est l’objet de dispositifs long terme
que l’on a au niveau de Clermont-Ferrand
et de mon unité de recherche.
La deuxième chose, c’est que
la prairie, c’est une richesse.
On dit que ce sont
des hotspots de biodiversité.
Les prairies font partie des écosystèmes
les plus riches en biodiversité.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose qui
nous intéresse énormément.
Simplement parce que la complexité
dans les systèmes vivants,
c’est leur fonctionnement,
leurs propriétés.
Plus on va avoir d’êtres vivants
qui vont interagir entre eux,
plus on va voir émerger
des propriétés intéressantes.
Notre travail de chercheurs,
c’est justement de travailler là-dessus.
Pour essayer de comprendre
ce mécanisme qui est complexe -
complexe, ça veut dire beaucoup de choses
que l’esprit ne peut pas seul appréhender.
Pour comprendre ça, on va prendre
l’exemple du carbone.
Le stockage du carbone,
vous en entendez parler,
c’est une solution absolument miracle.
On en a beaucoup parlé
au niveau des forêts
qui, elles, stockent essentiellement
le carbone dans leur biomasse.
Par contre, les prairies, elles,
vont stocker ce carbone dans le sol.
Entre 40 à 160 tonnes
de matières organiques
sont stockées dans les
dix premiers centimètres du sol.
Dix centimètres, ça fait ça.
C'est un capital qui est énorme,
extrêmement important.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c’est que cette solution naturelle
est totalement durable :
le carbone dans les couches profondes
date de plus de 2000 ans.
Ça n’a pas été fait à l’autre bout du
monde, mais dans la chaîne des Puys.
Ce sont des choses
extrêmement importantes.
C’est ce qui nous a conduits à essayer
de comprendre ces mécanismes-là.
L’autre élément extrêmement intéressant
est que, par son fonctionnement,
à la fois la végétation
et les micro-organismes du sol
vont contribuer à accroître
ce mécanisme-là.
Et d'année en année, ça s'accumule.
Les prairies permanentes
que vous voyez autour de vous
sont capables de stocker
plusieurs centaines [de kilos]
voire jusqu’à plus d’une tonne
de carbone par an et par hectare.
Ça a été mesuré dans des dispositifs
que l’on a juste à côté d’ici,
sur le site de Laqueuille.
Par contre, les prairies,
ce sont des écosystèmes gérés.
Ça veut dire que les prairies que
vous voyez ici dans le Massif central
n’existent que parce
qu’il y a des activités d’élevage
et que parce que l’homme entretient
depuis des dizaines d’années,
voire des siècles, ces écosystèmes-là.
Que va-t-il se passer ?
Si on arrête l’élevage, comme on voit
préconisé dans certaines publications,
la dynamique de végétation va continuer
et va faire que
l’on va évoluer vers une friche.
Cette friche, naturellement,
va être moins riche en biodiversité,
donc on aura moins de stockage
de carbone à terme.
Par contre, si on intensifie, c’est-à-dire
si on remet en culture -
ce sont aussi
des propositions que l’on voit :
faire moins d’animal, plus de végétal -
vous allez retourner le sol.
Cette remise en circulation
du carbone qui a été stocké
va entraîner un grand flush,
une grande émission de gaz
carbonique vers l’atmosphère.
Donc on se retrouve
face à un nouveau problème :
quelle utilisation des terres,
quel projet on va avoir
et quel va être le rôle des éleveurs
dans cette utilisation-là ?
Ça, c’est mon travail,
c’est le travail de nos équipes
où on essaye justement
de concilier et de proposer,
en mobilisant nos connaissances
sur le fonctionnement des écosystèmes,
des nouvelles solutions d’élevage.
L’hypothèse que l’on fait, c’est
que la biodiversité, c’est le rôle-clé.
On veut transformer l’élevage
en une solution fondée sur la nature,
mais pas n'importe quel élevage.
Ici, notre ressource essentielle,
c’est l’herbe ;
donc on va travailler
sur l’élevage à l’herbe.
C’est pour ça qu’il y a à peu près
trois ans, avec un collectif,
nous avons créé un laboratoire
d’innovation territoriale.
Il s’appelle « Élevage
à l’herbe de montagne ».
Le but, c’est non pas de partir de choses
que l’on va imposer aux éleveurs,
mais de partir d’initiatives
de terrain et de leur dire :
« On va financer la prise de risque, vous
accompagner dans ce que vous allez faire
et on va essayer d’évaluer tous ensemble
le poids de cette solution-là. »
Pour l’instant, on accompagne
cinq initiatives extrêmement diverses.
L’objectif, c’est de montrer
que la biodiversité peut être
un levier extrêmement puissant pour
combattre le réchauffement climatique.
J’espère que je vous ai convaincus que,
si certains systèmes d’élevage
contribuent au problème,
d’autres qui vont être plus
axés sur une ressource territoriale
respectueuse des hommes
qui travaillent sur ces territoires,
peuvent être aussi
un élément de la solution.
Merci de votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)
Présentateur : Merci Pascal.
Je vous rejoins sur la mousse.
Pascal Carrère : On va partager la mousse.
Vous nous avez parlé de quelques exemples,
mais sans trop entrer dans les détails.
Dans quelle mesure
le fruit de vos recherches
fait un peu évoluer
les pratiques sur le territoire ?
PC : Ce sont des choses
vraiment très pragmatiques.
On s’est rendu compte que
beaucoup d’éleveurs sont
des grands spécialistes de l’animal,
ils élèvent avant tout des animaux.
Mais leur ressource prairiale,
c’était essentiellement pour alimenter.
Ce que l’on a regardé, c’est de montrer
toute la diversité des prairies.
Par exemple, on a montré
qu’en fin de compte,
il y avait plus de 80 types différents
de prairies au niveau du Massif central,
que c’était une richesse
extrêmement importante
et que ça contribuait aussi
à la gestion de la biodiversité.
Expliquer à un éleveur
qu’en utilisant des ressources,
en ne faisant pas
des itinéraires techniques
mais en comprenant comment
les choses vont fonctionner,
il va devenir acteur de ses décisions.
C’est ce qu’on appelle
l’autonomie décisionnelle,
c’est-à-dire comprendre comment
les choses se font pour pouvoir y réagir.
Un exemple concret, extrêmement simple,
sur lequel on ne fait
que du transfert de connaissances
vers une population qui [représente]
les véritables acteurs sur le territoire.
P. : Merci Pascal pour cette vision
qui nous ouvre un peu plus
le champ des possibles.
PC : Merci bien, bonne soirée.
(Applaudissements)